[Music]
with the Christmas season upon us let's
recap the year today both for the wider
world as well as the great community
that we've built here at the Rubin
report note I did say Christmas season
they're not holiday season or winter
spectacular or whatever else the PC
crowd wants us to say these days the
fact is that the wide majority of people
in the United States do celebrate
Christmas and whether you celebrate it
or not there is goodness to be had in
the spirit of the season like being kind
to your fellow man when someone wishes
you a Merry Christmas that is not an
affront to Hanukkah Kwanzaa Festivus or
the cycle of the planets in many cases
probably most cases wishing someone a
Merry Christmas is more of just an
acknowledgement of the holiday season
rather than some sort of religious edict
of course by the same token if you're
offended that someone wished you happy
holidays instead of Merry Christmas
perhaps your offense meter is out of
whack to the point is that it's the end
of the year and 2016 has been
particularly divisive so let's try to
find some joy in one another and wish
good tidings even to people who weren't
that good to us this past year on the
world front 2016 will go down as one of
the craziest years ever Donald Trump
becoming the next president of the
United States was clearly the biggest
story but England choosing Bragg's it
instead of staying in the European Union
as well as the continued humanitarian
disaster in Syria will all have major
impacts as we move into 2017 and beyond
more than anything else though 2016
taught us that at least here in the West
the power is still with the people in
both Trump's win and the brexit vote the
vast majority of the media the elites
the establishment and the money was on
the other side yet despite this the
people rose up and changed the course of
the world with their votes now you may
not like the results of either of those
two events and you may not be happy with
the electoral college or with the
tactics of the brig's of tears but you
have to acknowledge that there's
something amazing in the ability of
people in a Western democracy to truly
control their own destiny most people on
earth would give
anything to have this much control over
the system that they live in
in fact the revolutions which swept
throughout the Middle East over the past
few years we're done with the hopes that
the people could one day have as much
sway over their leaders as we have in
the West right now while these
revolutions haven't worked out as
planned the seeds of freedom have been
planted and even if Egypt Libya and
obviously Syria aren't as free as we
want them to be the ideas of freedom
have taken root thanks to the internet
most of us now walk around with the
world in our pocket were connected in
incredible ways changing the world right
in front of us no longer do we have to
get our information from only a few
sources now any and all of us can be a
source of information all over the globe
of course this low barrier to entry
creates other problems like who can we
actually trust but I would always be on
the side of having access to more
information than less information just
look at how the mainstream media has
reacted to the Trump win do they offer
us any real introspection and reevaluate
their tactics and methods no of course
not instead they doubled down on
identity politics and name-calling and
at the same time the mainstream media
told us that anything not sanctioned by
them is fake news when the very people
who invented fake news are warning you
about fake news well you know the tide
is beginning to turn the issues that I
have tried to highlight over the past
year from the importance of free speech
to having honest political discourse
really encompass everything which moved
our world in 2016 the stifling of free
speech by using cries of racism and
bigotry shut down honest conversation
about relevant topics like Islamism and
immigration there's a direct line from
that stifling of hard but important
conversations that led us to brags it
and Trump coupled be inability or
unwillingness to have difficult
conversations about important issues
with the hyper partisan fighting that we
now have where people literally drop
friends and family members over
political disagreements and you have a
toxic stew having honest conversations
without resorting to demagoguery will be
Trump's biggest challenge
and it's one that I hope that he will
succeed at we know that Trump's good at
winning but will he be gracious enough
to understand that his win isn't just
for himself and his supporters but also
for the people who voted against him
even if they're still shouting about it
right this very second I really believe
that if Trump focuses on the economy and
infrastructure if he doesn't get us
involved in unnecessary military
conflicts and if he unleashes the tech
sector that we could have another
American Renaissance these are huge ifs
amongst many other ifs but right now if
you root for Trump to fail then you root
for our country to fail more important
than anything else if we had been able
to have more honest and enlightened
conversations in 2016 then perhaps the
world would feel a little more sensible
than it does right now you know it's
funny we don't like when people
discriminate on the basis of religion
which is simply a set of ideas but we
have no problem when people discriminate
based on political affiliation which
also is just a set of ideas tolerance of
different opinions will be our biggest
national challenge in 2017 accepting
that not everyone agrees with us all the
time and not only is that okay but it's
actually preferable will be something
that we all have to put into action in
this coming year we had our share of
groupthink in 2016 because everyone
seemed to go into their little bubbles
hopefully 2017 is where we burst them
and we see what happens
joining me this week is Tim Ferriss Tim
is no stranger to talking to people from
every walk of life and from every corner
of the globe his podcast the Tim Ferriss
show is over a hundred million downloads
and he's chatted with people from Sam
Harris and Arnold Schwarzenegger to Tim
Robbins and Kevin Costner he's been
described as the Oprah of podcasting and
his new book tools of titans is a
compilation of some of the best habits
he's learned from his various guests it
seems fitting to veer into the end of
2016 as an interviewer interviewing an
interviewer if 2016 was the year of
outrage then let's have 2017 be the year
of the conversation
you
[Music]